in this video you're gonna learn how to
find the remaining zeros when you're
given an imaginary or a complex 0 and
you have to find the remaining zeros so
what we have here is f of X equals this
polynomial and they're telling us 1 plus
I is one of the imaginary zeros now
notice that all the coefficients all the
numbers in front of the variables here
they're all real you don't see like
three I or 2i you don't see an imaginary
coefficients so when all the
coefficients are real like that
you have an imaginary zero we know that
these imaginary or complex zero come as
conjugate pairs what's a calm you get
well it's like if you have a plus bi
then you're going to have a minus bi or
in this case if we have one plus I we
also know one minus I as a zero that
come as those conjugate pairs like that
so you just change the sign in between
the real new manager part so what we're
going to do is since we know that 1 plus
I is a zero we're gonna do some
synthetic division ok so we're gonna use
our coefficients 1 negative 3 2 2 and
negative 4 make sure you're not skipping
any terms if you are put a zero there as
a placeholder and now we're just going
to do our synthetic division that's
going to bring it down from X to the
fourth to X cubed then when we do it
again with 1 minus I that will bring it
down to x squared once you get to x
squared you can do the quadratic formula
or a factor to find the remaining zeros
so let's go ahead and do this this part
here can be a little bit challenging you
always drop down the first number you
multiply on that diagonal and then you
add straight down so this is going to
give us negative 2 plus I now we have 1
plus I times negative 2 plus I you might
want to do this work off to the side so
1 plus I and negative 2 plus I so let's
see that gives us negative 2i negative
2i and I squared but remember I squared
is negative 1 plus negative 2 is
negative 3 so this is coming out to
negative 3 minus I we add straight down
so that's negative 1 minus I ok and so
now we're going to multiply on the
diagonal so this is gonna give us 1 plus
I times negative 1 minus I so let's go
ahead and do this we've got 1 times
negative 1 is negative 1 negative I
another negative i- i square
remember I squared is a negative 1 times
a negative is positive 1 plus negative 1
is 0 so this just comes out to negative
2 I add straight down so it's 2 minus 2i
now we multiply on the diagonal again so
we have 2 minus 2i times 1 plus I so
let's see we've got 2 times 1 is 2 2
times I is 2i negative 2i and negative
2i squared I squared is negative 1 times
negative 2 is positive 2 so this comes
out to 4 and these cancel and you can
see negative 4 plus 4 is 0 remainder
which is what we were expecting so now
we went from X to the fourth down to X
cubed we're going to do a synthetic
division now with the conjugate 1 minus
I so I'm just going to use these same
numbers here do the synthetic division
drop that first number down multiply on
the diagonal add straight down okay the
ice cancel multiplying the diagonal plus
I add straight down multiply on the
diagonal and straight down is your
remainder that's what we were expecting
because we knew that 1 - I was a 0 now
we went from X to the 4th to X cubed - x
squared so this is 1 x squared minus 1 X
minus 2 let's see if we can factor this
what multiplies to negative 2 but adds
to negative 1 that's negative 2 and 1
and you can double check by foiling so
now these are our remaining factors if
we set these equal to 0 we get X minus 2
equals 0 we can add 2 so x equals 2 here
we can subtract 1 so x equals negative 1
those are our remaining zeros now if you
couldn't factor it I would just do the
quadratic formula at this point to find
those remaining zeros so I hope this
video helps you I look forward to
helping in the future videos I'll talk
to you soon